we've got Amy Schumer uh-huh the college
instinct in me is like and the college
instinct is right this is exactly what
we wanted you to do got true guys I went
to a state school right here on the EVAs
red carpet finding out the most
important thing and that is who's the
best at flip cup let's find out you guys
look like a great team obviously you
probably could work together well have
you ever played flip Cup before when you
try to flip the cup over so put it on
the edge there
I've actually put it back over hold the
cup like this you flip it and estill and
I am a lesbian if it's a competition I'm
in I haven't played this in years good
luck damn that counts yeah ah crap was
that good
slow-mo that was amazing I never played
before with the assist
cheater liar cheater no I lose oh my god
yeah Queen yeah clean that was so sad no
that's it
I like this game a lot more okay Laurie
I'm so good at everything guys this is
getting get it I have to get you know
what I was a college I visited I went to
Towson University in Baltimore I went
and visited and I want to flip Cup
tournament and that's why I went there
so Hawaiian scholarship scholarship full
ride that's a crazy school don't
remember a day of it